you
[Music]
turns up you mediocre Millennials top 5
ends today guys ready let's rock it
smooth attack
Dragon Sword terminator power gold
dragon terminator power tyrannosaurus
Terminator power
yes for me blasphemy
get them
[Music]
number five Rangers gone psycho in an
effort to finally destroy the Power
Rangers astronomer creates the psycho
Rangers these evil incarnations
correspond to each color of the team and
are obsessed with their destruction very
powerful and relentless they use their
abilities to read the minds of each
space ranger to learn their fighting
styles their first few meetings proved
that the psycho Rangers are not to be
taken lightly the debut of the cycle
Rangers was an exciting one and started
a great arc for the show we have seen
doppelgangers of the Rangers in one-off
episodes before but these guys were here
to stay
at this point in the season korone had
just been forcefully reverted back to
astronomy and with the arrival of the
psychos Andros and his team were not
catching any breaks they get completely
whooped at the end of the episode and
the only reason they weren't destroyed
right then was because astronomer called
her team back the psycho Rangers are a
big part of Ranger history and this
episode did a great job establishing
them number four dark specters revenge
parts one and two a straddle that has
recently switched sides and is now with
her brother Andros and the other Rangers
dark Specter does not take this betrayal
lightly and wants her back he sends an
asteroid on a collision course with
earth which draws her own to the dark
fortress in order to reprogram its
coordinates the plane ultimately falls
apart and now the space Rangers must
figure out how to stop the asteroid and
save korone this two-parter was pretty
heartbreaking back in the day even now
it holds up well and Rose finally got
his sister back in the unexpected form
of astronomer only to lose her almost
instantly the acting is pretty decent
here and the premise of an asteroid
headed for Earth
presented a desperate situation for the
Rangers to overcome the debut of Zane's
mega winger helps push the asteroid off
course but the revelation of korone
being reverted back to astronomer
ultimately proved this mission to be a
loss for the Rangers besides the serious
stuff we get a fun side plot with bulk
skull and professor phenomenas that was
quite enjoyable
dragon tiger
[Music]
great job I think I'm getting a hang of
it number three always a chance during a
fight with astronomers latest monster
Liz wizard
Carlos accidentally injures Cassie and
begins to have serious doubts about
being a ranger when attacked again alone
Carlos is joined by Adam Park Carlos's
predecessor in the Rangers Adam tries to
help Carlos get over his fear of making
another mistake and hurting another one
of his teammates however as they train
it's obvious crows his issues are not so
easily solved this is probably one of
the most memorable episodes of the whole
Zordon era it was the first time we saw
this type of tribute to a former ranger
and Adam was a great choice
helping Carlos through his confidence
problem was the perfect role for him and
it makes me wish we could have seen some
other former Rangers pop up throughout
the season
seeing him morph again was an amazing
moment while you can debate how much
sense it makes that really doesn't
matter the story told here was great and
I think if you grew up watching the
first six seasons this is absolutely one
of the best episodes of the show period
number two astronomer thinks twice and
the Rangers leap of faith astronomer has
just learned the truth about her origins
and that Andros is her brother she is
torn between how she was raised and who
she was before being abducted by dark
onda as a child eventually she joins the
Rangers and gives them the location of
zorda but most of them are suspicious of
her motives and doubt that she should be
trusted at all this is probably the most
emotionally complex you can get with
Power Rangers astronomers realization
that Andros is her brother and
everything she's been taught her whole
life has been a lie create some really
well done scenarios for her to navigate
through we're not sure which side she's
on anymore and neither sheep credit
needs to be given to the ecliptic
character and how much he genuinely
cared for astronomy enough to let her go
with all the loyalties being shifted
around I gotta say I also love the Zoran
psych-out in the second episode
it's just that after all this time I
can't believe that you're still such a
fool what are you talking
Zordon
[Music]
no matter there's much more where that
came from
no the Gateway door has been destroyed
your pay for this
[Applause]
[Music]
and the number one best Power Rangers in
space episode is countdown to
destruction parts 1 & 2 dark specters
ultimate plan is finally set into motion
all the past villains the Rangers have
fought attacked different parts of the
entire universe at the same time the
Rangers are left as the last line of
defense on earth as astronomer looks to
destroy the planet herself I could make
a whole video in itself just about these
two episodes there's so much going on
designed as the finale for not just the
season but the Power Rangers series
countdown to destruction gave us a more
than epic battle to finish things up old
enemies return old allies are shown
fighting and Zordon makes his final
appearance while how things are resolved
is a little cheesy it's still a
satisfying conclusion and felt truly
epic and scale for Power Rangers it's
hard to not get wrapped up in everything
that's happening even all these years
later the battles the emotional strife
the goodbyes the new beginnings
everything is handled in a way that made
us feel invested in what we were seeing
some special moments in these episodes
included the obvious Rangers or Don and
astronomist ufff but Vulcan Skull leaing
the revolt against the invaders and II
clip doors final scene should not be
looked over I still think they did he
clipped her kind of dirty here if Rita
Zedd and freakin divatox survives or
Don's energy wave he should have - as
great as Power Rangers in space was were
there episodes of this season that
weren't so good yes and you can find out
which ones I didn't care for the most in
the top 5 worst Power Rangers in space
episodes up on my personal channel now
no rubs Prescott's
hasta la vista
[Music]
power down I don't believe it we won
believe it I can't thank you guys enough
and Jim you destroyed the Dynel
dimension door you do care whatever 100
episodes you've had a good run guys well
here's to 100 more
[Music]
you
I'm back that's cool